[Music]
hey rob
kayla from detroit michigan
all right my question is kind of dumb
but first thing i thought of
would you rather fight a bear-sized
chicken
or a chicken-sized bear it's like an
icebreaker
we asked all new people we meet love
your podcast
uh i love this question and by the way
thank you for being the very first
caller on our call line
i mean you should win some kind i mean
if we were a real podcast and we're
really thinking clearly we'd have some
kind of award for that you were the
first caller
and our lines are open um so
congratulations on that
um a bear sized chicken
or a chicken sized oh for sure a chicken
sized bear
100 it's not even a easy question
for me just the size i mean look
it's a chicken sized bear
so it's the size of two footballs
basically you could punt it
but a bear-sized
chicken coming at you with that beak and
all that crate just the size alone thing
look i keep it really simple i want to
fight
things that are smaller than me and i
don't want to fight things that are
bigger than me
that's my life lesson for the tip thank
[Music]
you